the gyro can experience it's not the
most outrageous article I need to find
out this is true so Jamie help me out
here they're saying that Amazon not
Amazon Whole Foods was asking their
employees to donate their sick time to
other people who might need it if they
get the coronavirus just stop and think
about that instead of saying hey you
work for us we got you
we'll take care of you we know this is
crazy times fortunately we have a lot of
money deeply it's like no no you guys
need to get your money together and take
care of your little problem because
we're over here it's craziest we're
making most of money I hope it's got
some good cheese dude I don't know who
makes that decision but I know who
should definitely never let that
massaging get get out that decision get
out there's Jeff Bezos he's the richest
man on earth so if he's the richest man
on the floor honey let him have his
money if he's the richest man on earth
and he knows about that he's like sounds
good to me
that's [ __ ] you know what the guy
works hard he got Whole Foods he's got
power he got a divorce and his wife was
she the richest female in the world now
off the divorce here we go have respect
look at this the CEO reportedly
recommends that employees donate to PTO
at a time on any time off to another
amidst the corona virus pandemic look at
that pretty okay they're going after him
for some reason we [ __ ] up he [ __ ]
[ __ ] Bezos the guy has five trillion
dollars I said why do you think the B we
get the burning on him he's protected
he's protected he made a deal with the
CIA see hey you don't think so don't you
think this is Naish you don't know about
Jesus Christ he's supposed to be
protected and their [ __ ] smearing him
he [ __ ] up he [ __ ] some I read it he
something happened because he was
protected okay protected and now they're
throwing him under the bus he hit on
somebody's wife hey you know who's nice
to get murdered like your boy
who supposedly commit suicide yeah but
your boy hard wines he's gonna go any
day now he thinks I'm gonna murder him
he has too much beef carpaccio he's this
celebrity to the celebrities how about
that Weinstein is is a thousand times
bigger and more powerful than Brad he
could make or break your career for the
phone call I'd suck is why nobody knows
who he is but every celebrity knows who
he was they were everybody knew who he
was too though they would and they're
friends with them they would say his
name when they went to exam speeches you
know my point is thank God he is immune
Hollywood well in Hollywood
nobody's himself piece of [ __ ] gonna
start going down one by one watch Tom
how much was the first one they got the
kingpin and now everybody Haven he did
big he's fine oh this is what you're
seeing is King behavior right when you
hear about mad Kings when you hear about
mad Kings when you hear about people
that are in these gigantic positions of
power and they act like savages and yell
at people and off with their head
knowledge and [ __ ]
that's King B he was the only one think
of assassinations at Kings what do you
think of you think of off with their
head kind of [ __ ] head off after the
picture but this is what happens when
someone gains absolute power like what
is that that old expression absolute
power corrupts absolutely
Harvey Weinstein was a piece of [ __ ]
yeah but Ryan that's also part of why
it's part of why he was a piece of [ __ ]
why he was a piece of [ __ ] because using
this incredible position of power and he
recognized that that was the way that he
could act out this power was to have
immense amounts of influence on people
and then he can get away with all kinds
of crazy [ __ ] and he could be the guy
that was untouchable
[Applause]